So in the last video I
hopefully proved to you, at
least maybe it doesn't make
intuitive sense just yet, but I
showed you that the probability
of a and b is equal to the
probability of a given b
times the probability of b.
And the probability of b given
a is equal to the probability
of b given a times a.
And then we played around a
little bit and we got this.
And this is called Bayes'
theorem or Bayes' law.
And I will now show you how
you can apply this formula.
But it shouldn't
be in a formula.
You should always be able to
intuitively come to this
conclusion, even if you forget
Bayes' theorem, which I do all
the time and then I go through
that thought process that
we did at the end of the
last video over again.
But let's see how we can
apply this to this problem.
So we want to figure out the
probability that we pick the
two-sided coin given that we
observed when we flip it
five times we got 5 heads.
So let's say that this is
event a and this is event b.
So we can use Bayes' theorem.
So the probability that I got
the two-sided coin, given 5 out
of 5 heads is equal to the
probability-- and I'm actually
going to think about what this
fraction means in a second.
But it means the probability
that I got a given
b, so it's this.
The probability that I got 5
out of 5 heads, given the
two-sided coin times the
probability of the two-sided
coin-- b-- we defined event
b as the two-sided coin.
Time the probability
of two-sided coin.
Divided by the probability of
in general, the probability
of getting 5 out of 5 heads.
Well, what's the probability
of getting 5 out of 5 heads
given the two-sided coin?
Well, we wrote that down.
We're guaranteed to get 5 out
of 5 heads, so that's 1.
And what's the probability of
getting the two-sided coin?
Well, that was 1/10.
And now what's the probability
of getting 5 out of
5 heads in general.
Well, we figure that out, I
think, either in the last video
or the video before that.
I forgot the exact number.
Actually, it was something
like 1/10 plus 9/320.
Right, so this is 32.
It was 41/320.
We figured that out in
the previous problem.
This is over 41 over 320.
And so what did we get?
We get this is equal
to 1/10 over 41/320.
Now what is that equal to?
That equals to 1/10
times 320/41.
Let's divide the top
and the bottom by 10.
So it equals 32/41.
That's interesting.
I actually find that
really interesting.
I don't know which coin I
picked out of the bag, but I
know that if I flip that coin
five times and all 5 are heads,
there's a 32 out of 41 chance--
this is maybe a little bit
better than a 75% chance that I
picked the two-headed
coin we could say.
And let's think about this
visually a little bit.
So if this is the entire
universe of what could happen,
and we said, 1/10 of that--
this is the two-sided coin,
this is the fair coin.
And then, out of all of that,
the situation in which we get 5
out of 5, well, those could
be-- if we got the two-sided
coin all of that is
going to be 5 out of 5.
And then some small fraction,
1/32 of the fare coin.
So this yellow circle
represents getting
5 heads in a row.
So if I want to know what's the
probability of the two-sided
coin, all Bayes' theorem is
saying, well, OK, we observed
that we got the two-sided coin.
Sorry, we observed that
we got 5 out of 5 heads.
So we now know that we're in
this yellow universe because
the yellow universe represents
the area or all of the outcomes
where we got 5 out of 5 heads.
And then we say, well, out of
those outcomes, what percentage
of them involved me getting
the two-sided coin?
Well, if we look here,
all of these-- sorry.
Edit.
If we look at it here, this is
the area out of the yellow
where I had the two-sided coin
and I got the 5 out of 5.
And so this is going to
be roughly 32 out of 41
of this yellow area.
So that's a visual
representation of
Bayes' theorem.
This says the probability of
getting a two-sided coin,
given I got 5 out of 5,
that says-- well, OK.
Let's look at the universe of
you got 5 out of 5, and then,
what percentage of that
universe involved you getting,
essentially the two-sided coin?
And that's that.
And that's all Bayes' theorem
essentially tells us.
So let's see if we
can apply that.
Let's do a more
interesting one.
Actually, I'm going to to leave
it there and then in the
next video I will apply
Bayes' theorem to more
interesting problems.
See you soon.